oui l'invité de ce journal andré pousse
le nom ne vous dit peut-être rien alors
regardez visage vous allez tout de suite
comprendre la gueule de truand la plus
célèbre de l'ouest en fait est
dorénavant un écrivain et son livre
c'est toucher par le souvenir 40 ans de
petites et de grandes histoires comme un
titre de cinéma en fait alors écrivain
c'est votre dernier métiers andré belaud
ses auteurs pour l'instant je ne suis
car des auteurs comme un métier mais en
fait vous en a fait vous en avez fait de
nombreux débris j'ai fait beaucoup de
métier j'ai été j'ai appris là je
voulais être béni ce qu'a relaté mme
rouge après le voir au bout d'un an ça
m'emmerdait j'évolue être mécanicien
j'ai appris la mécanique au bout d'un an
j'en avais marre et j'ai constaté qu'il
y avait un seul métier à l'époque on
avait un jour et demi de repos par
semaine c'est la boucherie
il fermait une heure le dimanche et hier
ouvrait le mardi matin et diamant perle
est rebouché du mali mme hom apprendre
la boucherie et après ça m'a fatigué un
peu et puis j'ai fait du vélo j'ai fait
de la boxe et puis j'ai fini par croire
cycliste professionnel ça le vélo vous
en effet très longtemps je t'ai dit
c'est fatigant pourtant pas et puis
après j'ai arrêté parce que j'en avais
assez je voulais vivre normalement
vous êtes devenu agent artistique louis
d'abord j'étais faire fortune d'haïti
par marcher je rentre à la nage ensuite
j'étais président de joséphine baker
henri salvador petula clark hallyday etc
j'ai fait des programmes du boulot ou du
casino du liban que j'ai ouvert du
cirque medrano de natal
en droit d'établissement à propos de
numéros de cirque que vous aviez parfois
du mal à trouver des numéros
complètement au point par exemple des
voltigeurs oui les quartette allait
prêter des quartets acrobatique c'est la
mode d'accès play boy alive encore four
qui étaient dissemblables et il avait
bien numéro points parce que je ne
m'engagerais jamais un numéro sans le
voir dans un studio de huit mètres de
plafond avec un fil comment dire sur un
plateau et la voltigeuse après deux ou
trois exercices
elle saluait il y avait les balances
heures qu'il accrochait après le corset
il achetait dans le public elle revenait
mais quand ils ont débuté ils ont débuté
à l'alhambra il y avait 26 m de saintes
alors les parties au deuxième balcon
quand on les revenus celle-ci de la
traquer les a couchés tout dans cette
patrie alors comment vous avez commencé
le cinéma en fait par hasard aussi comme
tout ce que j'ai fait